après trois semaines de silence l'heure
de vérité sa vérité
d'entrée de jeu le ton était donné dur
dit oui bourde affirme avoir été victime
de pressions inappropriée des efforts
répétés motivé politiquement dit-elle de
la part de 11 personnes pour que la
firme snc lavalin évite un procès
criminel a levé l'ex ministre évoque
même des menaces voilées
elle montre du doigt des membres du
bureau du premier ministre du conseil
privé et du ministre des finances lors
d'une rencontre avec le premier ministre
en septembre
justin trudeau aurait exprimé son
inquiétude pour les emplois chez snc
lavalin à plusieurs reprises
un conseiller du premier ministre
mathieu bouchard serait aussi intervenu
auprès de l'équipe de l'ex ministre
mais nous devons être réélu aurait dit
monsieur bouchard il ne peut y avoir de
solution sans ingérence aurait dit le
bras droit du premier ministre james
bond à sa chef de cabinet ces
interventions auraient dû cesser affirme
joe dit weir se met ball qui soutient
les avoir toutes repoussées hors les
tractations se seraient intensifiés même
de la part du greffier du conseil privé
prochaine mike bauer nick leur ai
prévenu en décembre qu'elle se dirigeait
vers un affrontement avec le premier
ministre mais ce genre de pression est
il illégal à son avis et ce non
immigrants à l aise
verryn propres et non dit elle mais très
inapproprié joe johnson ribot de
couronnes son témoignage de façon
fracassante
elle se dit convaincue d'avoir perdu son
poste de ministre de la justice à cause
du dossier
snc-lavalin pour le chef de l'opposition
officielle
un doux cieux il n'en fallait pas plus
je demande à justin trudeau de
démissionner
de plus la grc doit immédiatement ouvrir
une enquête
si on est là par déjà faire selon lui
justin trudeau a perdu l'autorité morale
pour gouverner loin de démissionner le
premier ministre maintient sa version
des faits
moi et mon personnel avons toujours agi
de façon appropriée et professionnels
je ne suis absolument pas d'accord avec
les conclusions
l'ancien procureur général justin
trudeau ne sait pas encore si il expulse
radio dit wilson webo de du caucus
libéral avec son témoignage l'ex
ministre voulait défendre non seulement
son intégrité mais aussi celle du
système de justice
ce sera aux canadiens de juger dit elle
et si louis blouin radio canada ottawa